hallo leute ich bin khadri das ist
francesco und das ist anders anderswo
sind wir heute
wir sind heute auf dem weihnachtsmarkt
auf dem weihnachtsmarkt gibt es
verschiedene dinge zu essen und zu
kaufen
das ist eine mittelalterliche burg aus
holz die kinder schießen auf die ritter
mit pfeil und bogen
die kinder springen auf dem trampolin
das ist ein typischer
weihnachtsmarktstand hier kann man zum
beispiel mützen und handschuhe kaufen
das ist ein kettenkarussell
das heißt so weil die sitze an ketten
hängen anders probiert mützen an
woanders diese mütze steht ihr aber
wirklich gut auf dem weihnachtsmarkt
gibt es immer viele sachen zum essen
anders sucht jetzt etwas zu essen
wir sind jetzt am waffelstand anders
kauft sich jetzt eine waffel halo eine
waffe mit dem und puderzucker bitte 50
bitte
[Musik]
dankeschön
das ist anders pafl
guten appetit anders schmeckt die waffel
sehr lecker anders hat gesagt dass die
waffel sehr lecker schmeckt hier gibt es
verschiedene skandinavische stände mit
spezialitäten aus island schweden
finnland und norwegen
was ist das das ist ein ding sie deutsch
kommt vom bodensee aus dem wilden süden
und ist ein brotteig der ist dann mit
schmand bestritten als basis aller sour
cream und dann kommt obendrauf zwiebeln
und ganz oben drauf mentaler und dann
geht's durch den ofen und wieder am ende
so aus das ist eine spezialität aus
süddeutschland und anders und francesco
dürfen jetzt probieren
francesco kommt aus italien
das ist ja wie eine deutsche pizza wie
schmeckte francesco es schmeckt super
gut
hier sind wir in einer kleinen holzhütte
die holzhütte heißt freak boutique
hier gibt es verschiedene sachen zum
beispiel souvenirs und magnete
schlüsselanhänger oder tassen und bücher
und kleine figuren aus metall anders und
francesco schlendern über den
weihnachtsmarkt
wir haben hunger deswegen gehen wir
jetzt zum pommes stand
wir nehmen eine currywurst und bitte
drei pommes zwei davon mit mayo und
einmal mit ketchup so die erste bombe
ist es fertig sie ist für janus
das ist eine kommission in der tüte
pommes ist noch sehr heiß
aber sie schmeckt sehr gut weil anders
aus indonesien kommt mag er gerne
scharfes essen
deshalb hat er sich promis mit schafen
zwiebeln bestellt ich probiere die com
ist es ist nur ein bisschen scharf nicht
sehr scharf anders ist es scharf ich
finde es nicht so scharf nimmst du seine
für ein genom esiea ist das gar nicht
scharf die populärsten stände auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt sind die glühweinstände
dort trinken die menschen heißen wein
zwei glühwein bitte
wie viel macht das hast du schon 50 cent
hh
juni 6
wir haben es passend
danke schön hier francesco dein glühwein
ich trinke jetzt mit francesca glühwein
rhein ist roter wein der heiß gemacht
wird eigentlich mag ich gar keinen roten
wein aber wenn er warm ist und es
draußen kalt ist dann ist es lecker
francesco
[Musik]